what I love about CFS in 2018 I can't do
everything
[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to 2008
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my favorite part of CSS comp is always
the meeting new people and hearing the
conversation it gives developers and
engineers and designers a chance to
connect with each other in a way that
they don't get to in their normal
day-to-day work inspire each other and
talk about the work that they do with
people outside of their own companies or
organizations and so it can open
developers minds to context and
situations that they don't encounter in
their daily work I think community
events are really important because I
came from a really small town in the
southeastern United States and I didn't
really find a sense of belonging there
and it just it blows my mind that I came
to Berlin and found this amazing
community so far away it's nice to be in
a place where everyone can come together
and celebrate CSS and all its quirks
together see what's coming up and see
what we can do to make it even better
for everyone in 2015 I was one of the
scholarship holder I had a lot of
opportunities to be a speaker and also
landed up in a job in Berlin this
scholarship is a is a great means to
help diverse candidates explore
opportunities new opportunities
[Music]
[Music]
this has confessed run by a volunteer
team the curation like all the little
details that we see here the design is
all done by volunteers that have known
each other for years
and all of us still remember the very
first year where we just all had this
desire to set up an event to talk about
CSS because there was no place for it
before my talk was about how we can
build safe teams and a better culture
and environment East Asian photography
and how it can inspire more than web
layouts building a dev tools extensions
API that people could use to create
their own tools for web designers on top
of dev tools I thought was about Design
Systems as facilitators and applying
facilitation lens to products that we
use I would say my talk was about
empathy and the fact that you really
need multiple layers when you're talking
about empathy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's been fantastic to be able to
welcome so many wonderful people from
around the world once again this year
thanks everyone for making it such a
great event
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]